dozens of Agents sprinted across the
blacktop weapons drawn they fired
indiscriminately at the building ahead
of them they only had a matter of
minutes to stop this mad Plan before it
was too late but navigating the air base
was proving to be almost impossible
banana peels littered the runway
tripping them over at nearly every step
colorful plants were springing up
through the cracks and snaring their
boots and chomping at their ankles with
rudimentary teeth somewhere high above
them a mutant reptile was throwing
hammers at their head from atop a cloud
of white gas the agents struggled and
fought their way to the hangar but it
was too late the rumbling of engines the
belch of smoke the crashing sound of a
hole being blasted through the roof they
were too late out of the smoking hanger
Rose and Airship painted a sickening red
and composed of hunks of scrap metal the
ship was shaped like a top hat there was
a globe on the deck and a sail billowing
out of the top the door to the Airship
crashed open and out of it burst a man
with a bushy mustache denim overalls and
a red hat his eyes burned lit up with
the flame of a man with nothing to lose
he stared down at the agents below him
with a carnal Fury watching as they were
chomped crushed and blown up beneath him
but then his eyes drifted up higher into
the sky toward the prize that he was
really after the one thing that would
bring the love of his life back to him
the moon the Airship puffed out a thick
cloud of awkward smoke and shot off into
the air Rising higher and higher as the
crazed Italian growled from its deck
Circle Yahoo
let's ago New York City the city that
never sleeps or rather the city where
you can never get to sleep the constant
car horns drunken yells and general
chaos of Manhattan can really get to you
especially if you live in a cheap
apartment over a convenience store Max
had been living here for the better part
of a year now and the only way he found
to unwind on the busy nights was to sit
down in front of the TV and play video
games sleep was off the table so that
was the next best thing the pipes under
his sink were busted but he couldn't be
bothered to call in a plumber he had
better things to spend his money on he'd
been desperate to buy a switch for years
but they just hadn't dropped in price in
true Nintendo fashion he was pretty sure
if he fast forwarded to the apocalypse
he still wouldn't be able to find a
switch for anything less than full price
staying up late checking out Ebay
options he'd unbelievably actually found
one some grandma was selling it along
with all her grandson other games
according to the item description her
grandson had been hospitalized after he
broke both his hands trying to punch a
tree apparently he needed the wood to
build some kind of table anyway he'd
been banned from playing any games as a
punishment since he was getting too
obsessed with them so lo and behold a
used Nintendo switch was in Max's hands
he'd been waiting for years to play
Super Mario Odyssey after watching the
Mario movie the other day he couldn't be
more in the mood to sit down and play
supposedly one of the best games of all
time and play it Max did eyes glued to
the screen he sat there on his couch all
the way through the night Mario leaped
through the cat Kingdom with ease
stomped his dinosaur feed through the
Cascade Kingdom conquered the sand
Kingdom while jamming out to the music
and plowed on after fully exploring each
kingdom he'd hop onto his hat-shaped
Airship and flying to the next one all
Friday night he played and didn't even
realize when the sun came up on Saturday
morning he loved to see all of his
favorite characters on screen Bowser in
his white suit Cappy and all of his
spinning Glory Peach looking radiant as
usual and Sam Max racked his brains he
was trying to remember if he'd ever come
across this guy's Sam in a Mario game
before he was just some Koopa much like
any of the others except he had a white
shell every world that Mario would visit
Sam would be there somewhere often
hidden under a sphinx or behind a
waterfall it was the same dialogue
option each time whenever Mario
approached Sam a speech bubble would pop
up I want salt and meats bring them to
me hurry up but try and see Mike Max
couldn't find any items resembling salt
or Meats anywhere in the game what would
they even look like it all seemed very
out of place compared to the moons he
was supposed to be collecting it was
only once Max reached new donk City and
met Sam standing shiftily in a back
Alleyway that the dialogue changed no so
to Meats huh solve the food shortages
Max tried talking to him again but the
game wouldn't let him no matter what he
did he couldn't interact with Sam
anymore he searched all over New donk
City looking for anyone who could Point
him in the direction of some salt or
Meats but there was nothing none of the
other characters mentioned anything
about food shortages that was enough of
that taking his headset off Max sat back
on his couch and rubbed his eyes how
long had he been playing for long enough
to work up a real appetite planting both
hands on his knees Max pushed himself to
his feet and wandered over to the fridge
there wasn't much in there a bowl of
leftovers some cheese a few options but
nothing like what he was really craving
he pushed his way through the back and
his eyes lit up there behind everything
else was a little box he'd forgotten to
throw out the previous week mushrooms
would they still be good to eat he
didn't care taking gone off mushrooms by
the handful he shoved them into his
hungry mouth that's how he would grow
big and strong with a satisfied smile he
slammed the fridge door closed and
stared at himself in the mirror he must
have been gaming for a long time a thick
tuft of hair had appeared on his upper
lip looking this way and that Max
admired the mustache in the Morning
Light muttering under his breath Mamma
Mia
scp-3843 is a little-known bug that
appears in physical video games much
like a biological virus it is
transmitted from one copy of a game to
another through close proximity if one
game in a collection exhibits evidence
of
scp-3843's presence it likely means that
all other games in the owner's
collection also have become infected but
what is
scp-3843 well that much is currently
unclear the game's coding appears to
undergo no changes when affected and yet
a new non-player character appears when
the game is booted up how this character
manifests depends on the video game
itself but the there are a number of
consistent rules firstly the character
always fits within the world of the
video game with a small identifying
feature a white-shelled Koopa and Mario
an extra crew member on the Normandy in
Mass Effect 2 and even a diamond-shaped
block in Tetris with a hole cut out of
the middle secondly this NPC is always
identified as Sam or some variation of
that name if it is necessary to change
it to fit the world for example in Elden
ring
scp-3843 takes on the name Sam of The
Starving planes or in Pac-Man it becomes
Sammy one elusive characteristic of
these NPC characters is their obsession
with salt and meats in the majority of
incarnations any which allow the
character to have dialogue Sam always
expresses a desire to be given salt and
meats with follow-up dialogue usually
complaining of food shortages on
occasion the game will contain
additional food items that seem to be
generated by scp-3843 for example when
Sam appears as a merchant in near
automata it will sell you cubes of a
non-descript salty meat if the player
chooses to consume those items nothing
appears to happen tracking down
instances of scp-3843 has become easier
in recent years the decline of physical
game sales with the shift to a more
digital ecosystem has meant that
transmission between copies has reduced
significantly a physical disk or
cartridge is required for transmission
after all what is more Foundation
testing has revealed that this SCP is
incapable of infecting online only games
multiplayer Shooters and mobas are
totally immune to it in fact any game
that requires an internet connection to
play will be immune to transmission
while Gamers do hate the trend of having
to be online to play their single player
games there is a big upside to it from
the foundation's perspective who knows
perhaps there are agents placed in
certain publishing Studios pulling some
strings to help crack down on
scp-3843 transmission it wouldn't be the
first time the foundation has meddled
with the gaming industry to try and
control the outbreak little-known
developer Indigo games launched in 1980
to relatively small Fanfare they flew
under the radar over the three years of
their existence closing up shop in 1983
but their effect on the games industry
was enormous as they are believed to
have been the source of the original
instance of
scp-3843 with the sale of physical games
blowing up early in the 80s it was the
Prime circumstances for Sam to spread
like wildfire without much other choice
the foundation had to step in due to
large number of
scp-3843-1 instances becoming public in
1983. the foundation resorted to
emergency containment measures to
achieve this they caused a crash in the
video game Market by using their
resources to influence major players
this involved financing competing home
computer companies artificially
saturating the market using
foundation-owned companies and
undercover elements in existing
companies using Foundation elements to
encourage poor business practices in
existing game Publishers and sabotaging
upcoming projects it was a success the
gaming industry slumped and sales fell
through the floor buying enough time for
the foundation to get on top of
instances of
scp-3843 You Must Be Wondering by now
what's so bad about Sam just a harmless
NPC popping up in video games asking for
salt and meats where's the harm in that
you would be right in the context of the
game no real damage was being done the
issue came from the real World
repercussions of encountering Sam you
see when someone chooses to interact
with shopkeeper Sam start Quest Giver
Sam's storyline or engage mini boss Sam
in combat it marks the beginning of a
physiological change in the player what
this looks like depends on the game for
Zelda breath of the wild it's just a
case of the person growing blonde hair a
higher pitched voice and developing a
sudden affinity for swordsmanship puzzle
solving and hang gliding the player
undergoes physical change to make them
more closely fit into the world of the
game that they are playing while also
gaining Knowledge and Skills akin to
what their player character would
possess the first instance of this
posing a real world threat was when
Daryl McKenzie 24 was shot dead whilst
infiltrating a U.S military base after
playing an infected copy of Metal Gear
Solid before his death he had exhibited
high-level Espionage and combat
proficiency which his family all claim
he had no knowledge of prior to this
event other cases can be even more
severe such as when the player character
is not just a regular human infected
copies of cyberpunk 2077 and Deus Ex
mankind divided resulted in players
growing electronic implants in their own
bodies which most often leads to death
as their immune system rejects the
technology instances where the players
control non-human creatures are even
more severe one woman sprouted cat ears
and thick fur all over her body before
suffering multiple organ failure an
agent checking her PC found that she had
over 1 000 hours logged as a Khajiit
character in Skyrim often the foundation
is only a couple of steps behind
infected game copies and so is able to
step in and help those affected this
unfortunately was not the case with Max
three weeks passed and Max felt like he
was on top of the world he fixed the
problem under his sink no problem after
finding he suddenly had a wealth of
Plumbing knowledge somewhere in his
brain he'd gone through his entire
wardrobe and thrown out all the awful
clothes he used to wear replacing them
with much better outfits red cats denim
overalls big brown shoes it was the
perfect look for him every morning he
would sit in front of his mirror and
sculpt his mustache to Perfection
carefully trimming the hairs to the
exact right shape exploring new dunk
city was his favorite pastime he'd kick
open the door to his apartment and
stroll out onto the street looking for
Adventures every day jumping on the
roofs of taxis playing jump rope in the
park with children exploring the sewers
looking for Adventures swinging around
the flagpole on the Empire State
Building he was having a fantastic time
despite all the looks he was getting
from passersby but one thing played on
his mind the whole time Peach she was
still under Bowser's control it wasn't
fair of him to have all this fun while
the love of his life was a prisoner he
needed to collect enough moons That's
What mattered but no matter where he
looked in new donk City he just couldn't
find any the only Moon he could see was
the one sitting there in the night sky
staring out of his apartment Window
Mario Max hatched a plan his apartment
was slowly coming to life around him
little piranha plants grew out of the
pots on his windowsill he'd bought a gun
a few days ago and already the bullets
had grown little faces and arms he was
assembling a small Arsenal here enough
to take the Moon by force he heard the
pounding footsteps before the door to
the hangar flew open an agent stood
there holding a gun in trembling fingers
staring into the darkness Max let a
smile slowly creep across his face as
his gloved hand hovered over the launch
controls the agent called out into the
Shadows who's there it's
Max cranked the lever forward and his
Airship kicked into the sky Mario
gunfire rang out from all directions as
the ship Rose into the air he cackled
maniacally on the deck watching the
agents get torn apart by all this traps
they weren't going to get in the way of
him reaching his Princess Peach not
today on the ground agents stared up as
the Hat ship flew away from them higher
and higher into the sky only the faint
echo of a
drifted down to their ears before Max
ran out of oxygen and passed out on the
deck of his ship now check out scp-049
fights scp-343 as the referee Dr bright
starts a fight club and scp-1471 Mal o
but hacked Minecraft for more